fissiles et je sais que jeune rachid
fait beaucoup rire ah bah oui mais je
pense que je suis pas le seul
mais si je ne sais pas combien il ya de
gens qui les suivent sur sa chaise à 1,8
million de vues sur ce court métrage
alors un soir d'octobre les colocataires
mohamed et raphaël se dispute sur leur
origine et l'état de la france à un
incroyable voyage dans le temps va
couper court à leurs disputes et les
deux locked des deux colocataires vont
se retrouver le 17 octobre 1961 à paris
et ce jour là la france basculé dans
l'horreur avec la répression policière
sanglante contre une manifestation
pacifique d'algériens alors les jeunes
rachid ils m'ont fait des trucs vraiment
top
parce que c'est toujours intelligent et
c'est toujours drôle regardez jour
depuis déjà 1,8 million de vues regardez
un extrait vos papiers s'il vous plaît
on a perdu sa langue mais c'est s'aimer
employé italien il parle pas encore
français
si si mac et catenaccio la cigale gym
fun comme la cantine haute et a baladé à
part des ministères démarre et hadi est
sous la barre atb gamme de reason
tarou toi d'où tu sors ça vieux bois
l'egypte partie du site et j'ai fait
trois ans et si ces paliers au prince et
réalisé par antoine hosni totalement
totalement qui est très bon sur scène
aussi et là on ne pense que c'est un
tout petit peu drôle mais c'est drôle et
touchant c'est vraiment à cette horrible
et je le traite de manière un peu drôle
et un peu un peu tous chantent aussi
c'est déjà un carton 1,8 million de vues
parce que ça a fait ses vues sur youtube
mon public est là je serai content de
montrer à un autre public que j'ai pas
forcément que ça touche un maximum de
personnes ça me fait plaisir et c'est
grâce à toi est ce que personne d'autre
qui m'a invité
pour gagner c'est vraiment un des mecs
qui me fait le plus rigoler avec et jean
luc lemoine aussi qui est là sans plus y
aller 4/3 et je sais que généralement
j'en prends plein la gueule l'hôtel
savana